Hey guys, Pete here. Today I'm going to do
a Dark season 2
ending explain video for you. If you're
looking for answers to Dark's big
mysteries,
I regret to tell you that you'll have to
wait until season 3 is released to get
that type of clarity.
But, after nearly a year of thinking
about the season 2 finale
it feels like the right time to break
down what happened and where things were
left to set up the ending of one of my
favorite tv shows.
I've already put together a recap of the
second season. If it's been a while since
you watched season two I recommend
watching that
as well to remember everything that
happened. Because i've already done that
I can just focus on the ending
of season two in this video. In case this
is the only Dark season 2 video you're
going to watch
before season three comes out, I will
recount the big revelations that we got
in the second season.
The first was that Noah isn't the big
bad in the story.
He follows a man named adam who is the
leader of a group called Sic Mundus.
we learn that Adam is actually Jonas, the
oldest version of him that we've met.
This means that there are two major
factions in the story led by Adam and
Claudia. This is all fairly complicated
considering that alliances change
throughout time. Adam and Sic Mundus's
goal
appears to be to destroy the world, but
he tells people he's in a war with god
which is
time. Claudia wants to stop Adam. She
sells that as wanting to save the world
and there's a component of changing
small details of things
which will lead to a different outcome.
Another big revelation was that
Elisabeth and Noah
are Charlotte's parents. This means that
Charlotte is both the daughter and the
mother of Elisabeth which makes for a
paradoxical family tree.
As far as time travel is concerned there
were no major changes
in how things work. based on what's
observable Dark appears to be occurring
in a deterministic system where nothing
can be changed despite what some of the
characters say or try to do.
Tannhaus does introduce the idea of a
bootstrap paradox.
Very simply this explains how something
can cause its own existence by being
sent back in time.
it exists in a cause and effect loop
with no point of creation. he uses his
book as an example which he wrote after
reading a copy
that Claudia gave him from the future. it
would take a whole separate video
to explain the observable rules for time
travel in Dark so i'm not going to get
into it here, but i will revisit it at
the end
because one of the biggest revelations
comes in the final moments of the ending
when we learn that there's at least one
alternate world or reality.
So, what happened at the ending of Dark
season 2? The final episode opened in
2053 where the older Elisabeth is
preparing for the day of the apocalypse.
she looks at photos of her daughter and
mother Charlotte from when she was a
baby.
Elisabeth is the leader of the survivors
in the contaminated restricted zone
around the nuclear power plant. they are
followers of a prophecy related to Sic
Mundus
and are waiting for the passage to
reopen on this day.
in 2020 stranger Jonas grabs the gun
Boris Niewald brought with him to
Winden from the box that Hannah kept it
in.
he also looks at the spot on the floor
where his younger self will see Martha
die
later. the gun he's grabbing is the same
gun that will be used to kill her so
this is a really nice touch
that shows he has experienced her death
before. he echoes this to her
when he goes to her house saying, "I saw
you die once.
I won't let that happen again." when she
won't come along with him he uses the
same gun to force her into the bunker.
he's trying to keep her safe from the
apocalypse. at this point he should know
that she's not going to stay there but
he still has to try,
Katharina arrives at the Kahnwald house
with the time machine
and finds Michael's map of the caves and
the hand lamp. she runs into stranger
Jonas when he returns
who now believes he can't change the
fact that he'll become Adam, but believes
he might be able to stop him.
at the caves young Jonas is with middle
Claudia not long after she watched her
father Egon die.
in their conversations we see how he is
under the influence of older Claudia and
how that drives his decisions.
it's interesting that he's guided by
this idea of trying to change small
things that will produce a different
outcome all the way up until the time he
closes the portal in the season one
finale. Jonas activates the machine in
the tunnel and that reopens the passage.
the other characters around then then
all notice that something is happening.
Katharina asks stranger Jonas what it is
and he explains that the passage in the
caves is being reopened.
she sees this as an opportunity to try
to find Mikkel and leaves the house with
Michael's map to try to travel through
the passage.
she leaves the time machine that she was
carrying there.
after they opened the passage Jonas
tells middle Claudia he's going to find
his mother and Martha
and for her to go find Regina and take
her to the bunker
Peter and Elisabeth Doppler go to the
bunker as well and when they open the
door Martha escapes
in 1921 Noah confronts and tries to kill
Adam. Adam says they can't escape their
fates
and says that it's not Noah's fate to
kill him on that day.
when Noah presents the missing pages
from the notebook he says
you're not waging war against god you're
waging it against humankind.
Adam isn't worried because he believes
it's not his fate to die
and watches as the gun jams on Noah
making it impossible for him to kill him.
Adam's belief is that this knot, this
world we've been introduced to
with Jonas at its center, can only be
undone by destroying it completely.
this seems to support noah's belief that
Adam is waging war against humanity
Noah won't be around to see how it plays
out though because Agnes enters the room
and kills him.
unlike her brother she is able to use
the gun and shoots him with Adam's
approval.
older Noah's story ends there and we see
his younger self arrive in 2020 in the
next shot.
he arrives at the Kahnwald house with the
letter for stranger Jonas and he says
it's from Martha based on what we've seen
this can't be from the original Martha so
we're left to wonder if Adam wrote it or
if it was written by alt-Martha who we'll
meet later.
he looks emotional and seems shocked by
what he reads and takes off with the
time machine
after Noah tells him that he has to save
Magnus, Bartosz, and Franziska. we don't
know what the letter says but the
mention of saving Agnes and Noah later
is interesting
thinking of what Jonas cares about we
could speculate that Magnus and
Franziska need to be saved in order to
produce a child that would be important
for the rest of the family trees
if that child was Agnes then the Martha
he fell in love with wouldn't exist
unless she's born since she's the
farthest point back on the Nielsen line
that we know of
none of that is confirmed and i didn't
like this theory at all when i first
heard it but there is some sense to it
and it would explain what was inside
that letter that made him change his
mind about trying to kill Adam
in the lead-up to the event at the power
plant Katharina enters the caves
older Elisabeth enters the dead zone in
to activate the god particle machine
there Adam gets ready and then travels
to 2020 and then later we see his
machine being
activated again charlotte arrives at the
power plant just as Clausen is
discovering the barrels
and young jonas arrives at his house
just before Martha arrives
they have a heartfelt reunion and kiss
passionately until they're interrupted
by adam's arrival
adam then kills martha telling jonas he
will carry that pain with him for the
rest of his life until he's ready to let
go of her
her death is necessary to jonas's
transformation into adam and adam needs
the apocalypse to happen so that he can
use
the dark matter to destroy the knot and
it does happen
and i described it in greater detail in
my season 2 recap
the quick explanation is that Clausen
opening the barrels
leads to a portal opening up connecting
to 2053. elisabeth and charlotte see
each other through it and they touch
hands just before
Winden is destroyed reflecting on the
ending one of the things i find most
fascinating is the convergence of all
three jonas's at the same place in the
finale
and what their motivations are at
different points in the same life
remember jonas just spent a year with
the older claudia where he essentially
joined her side
with the intention of changing things
what they did during that year is still
a mystery but he tells middle claudia
that their goal is to make it so none of
this happens
he had already turned away from adam
after his first trip to 1921
because of the deception over the
suicide and i feel pretty confident in
saying that watching martha die at adam's
hand
probably didn't change things just a few
months earlier during the season 1
timeline
stranger jonas tried to close the portal
with the machine
hoping that changes he made might have
made a difference
it didn't work and in the process he
came to the realization that he couldn't
change anything
he changed his focus to killing adam
rather than trying to alter what's
already happened
when he receives the letter he realizes
that he has to save
magnus bartosz and franziska and that
leads him to travel to the past where he
will inevitably become
adam by killing martha adam ensures that
his younger self is on the path to
become the stranger and then eventually
him
the apocalypse happening sets up the
rest of his plan
the final thing that happens in the
season is that young jonas is saved by
an alternate version of martha
who basically tells him she's from a
different world she has a completely
different look than the marta we know
and has what looks like a much advanced
time machine that presumably also allows
her to travel between
worlds she whisks jonas away at the last
second
and we literally don't know anything
else about how she fits into the story
as i mentioned in myonas's journey
through time video where i mapped out
his path through seasons one and two
the big questions are the periods of
time when he transitions from one
version to the next we have to imagine
that some of the time between
young jonas and the stranger occurs in
that old world
what that alt world is how it works and
how it influences the bending that we
know
are currently a mystery so what does it
all mean well based on what we've seen
to this point
it seems like we're looking at a
deterministic system where everything
that happens already happened
and nothing can be changed despite what
the characters have said
we haven't seen any evidence to
contradict this if that's the case you
could think of time as a line where all
the events are laid out from beginning
to end
since time travel exists characters can
visit different points on the line
and experience them out of order but
everything is mapped out
and happens only once for example martha
nielsen was shot and killed jonas
happens to be there at two different
points in his life but there is only one
event his older self
shoots her and his younger self watches
her die it only happens once even though
he sees it from his perspective
twice where things get confusing is that
characters throw around this idea of
cycles the term cycles and that isn't
clearly defined
what makes the most sense to me is that
a cycle would be one person
experiencing an event from their
perspective at different points in time
since the final cycle is supposed to
start on june 27
2020 the apocalypse is probably the
event
when adam arrives to kill martha this
would be the third point in his life
that he's experienced this
from his perspective that could be what
he's talking about when he says the
start of the third cycle
i'm not married to this idea but it's
hard to come up with something else that
doesn't violate this closed structure
where the characters don't have free
will
my hope is that they define what adam is
talking about early on in season three
and will get a clear understanding of
how alt marta wound up saving jonas from
the apocalypse the first time he
experienced it
Tannhaus's hypothesis in his book a
journey through time
is time is not linear past present and
future are intertwined and
influence one another we also have the
trinity knot notebook the triquetra
notebook with everything that happens
leading up to the apocalypse already
written down
several characters have seen the
notebook and followed what was written
inside it and its existence
indicates someone knew everything that
would happen we don't know who wrote it
or where it came from and that's just
one of the mysteries we got bouncing
around
there's a lot of mystery and a lot of
unanswered questions going into the
final season
there are some things we do know though
we know who lived and who died and where
some of the characters are at
who died in season two well the man at
the cave who is most likely the older
Bartosz
he was killed by younger noah and adam
sent him to do it
noah died when he was shot by a sister
agnes under the church
we also saw the graveyard by the church
in 2053
there were a lot of wooden crosses
marking graves they all looked the same
and were all likely victims of the
apocalypse
we saw markers for Woller and aleksander
tiedemann and others just in case you
didn't think this giant black ball
slash explosion thing would kill
everyone in the city
Woller was at the power plant and
aleksander was
in the police station the church itself
is destroyed
and that probably means adam's god
particle twin machine is gone as well
although there's no way to tell since
jonas wouldn't have known about it when
he first traveled to 2052
we're not really sure if claudia knew
about it younger noah would have known
about it but we don't know if he would
have told any of the other survivors
older claudia was killed by noah and of
course marta prime was killed
and all these characters are dead but
because of time travel
it's certainly possible that they will
pop up in season three
the survivors and where they are hannah
traveled to
1954 and she's still there when the
apocalypse happens as far as we know
we've yet to see an older version of
hannah but do know that she left ulrich
where he was
and we've seen the older version of him
she also told aegon that
she was looking for a fresh start which
sounds like she may stay
in that time period older magnus and
presumably older franziska
are still in 1921. the best guess is
that adam would have returned to the
church and traveled back to join them
there
after he killed martha everyone in the
bunker is still alive
middle claudia regina peter young
elisabeth and young noah
of course those two will form a
relationship that will later produce
charlotte claudia has a time machine
with her and she will be researching the
god particle we know that from the tapes
and the stuff that she left behind in
we don't know what's up with peter or
regina at this point
regina still has cancer stranger yonas
and magnus franziska and Bartosz travel
somewhere that will eventually lead them
back before 1921.
the stranger will become adam build the
church in the god particle twin time
machine
and form sic mundus katharina entered
the passage
traveling to either 1954-1987
we'll have to wait and see where she
exits since jonas
and young helga both survived when they
touched through the portal at the end of
season one
there's reason to believe that elisabeth
and charlotte will survive as well
it's a different situation to be sure
though since the area where charlotte is
currently is in the process of being
destroyed i don't think we could say
where they'll end up based on what
happened the last time
when jonas and helga touched each other
one person traveled 66 years and the
other traveled 33
and that's what we know and what can be
explained i'm going to leave it there
if you have questions leave them in the
comments i'll try to answer what i can
it looks like they're going to be
announcing season 3 any day now
so be sure that you subscribe to my
channel because i'll be doing more
videos leading up to season 3.
please like this video if you enjoyed it
and tell me what you think in the
comments
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon